[Musica]
buonasera mi chiamo claudia è la prima
canzone che vi canto e don abbondio si
chiama don abbondio potreste chiedervi
perché don abbondio cosa c'entra con
questa giornata
questo questo nome questo titolo questa
c'entra con questo argomento con la
terra in effetti all'apparenza d'un
abbondio potrebbe semplicemente
ricordarci quel personaggio manzoniano
scritto tanto tanto tempo fa in realtà
l'autore di questo brano dario brunori
ci spiega che don abbondio non è solo
questo
don abbondio viva in ognuno di noi e don
abbondio don abbondio siamo noi
don abbondio sono io quando dimentico
che la terra il bene comune più grande e
più bello di cui disponiamo e faccio di
tutto a qualsiasi costo difendo il mio
piccolo orticello anche magari a
discapito degli altri e attuando
comportamenti illegali e senza curarmi
delle conseguenze questo è don abbondio
[Applauso]
[Musica]
tra uno strazio del mio mare diventa
lo stato delle cose che ormai dato per
scontato nella farsa tragicomica di una
trattato stradale nelle morte per
sopra un letto d'ospedale donà
il fondo nell'assenza don abbondio
funerale della nostra coscienza sono
ponde solo io
affacciato alla finestra a contare le
macerie
a guardare quel che resta no
ecco
si no
[Musica]
ho letto che possono succedere
dalla tandja mia nipote
lo dobbiamo sistemare
presenti all'evento
il consigliere
tra le mani che siano relish a un seggio
elettorale dona vogliono la schiena che
si piega
che prezzi sono figli
andato a podio sono io
per la finaliss
raccontare le macerie
a guardarla
sesto anno
no
[Musica]
sono buoni abbiamo non è vero il mio
dialetto non madonna che s'inchina paure
per rispetto verso nuove insomma di un
cristo che la bene così nera che nessuno
lo ha mai visto lavorare al buio nero
però come detto di no perché gli hanno
preso tutto col botto il mio sport che
si è fatto sempre
per paura che agli indizi poi si
aggiungono le prove
no
cosa no no no
no no no
no
[Musica]
no no
d'estate
la faccia da padrone e che non deve
solo
[Musica]
di sera
[Applauso]
la seconda canzone che ho scelto l'ho
scelta perché la ritengo essere la
canzone cosmica per eccellenza è un
brano scritto nel 1967 da john lennon
[Musica]
si tratta di un brano che abbraccia in
una visione di insieme la terra
l'umanità una dimensione spirituale e
mistica proprio com'era spirituale
l'esperienza musicale dei beatles di
quel periodo
across the universe
[Applauso]
[Musica]
roster
ciao
va
no
si no
[Musica]
c'è
scola
all
[Musica]
sconcerto
deciso
questa
[Musica]
così
a crosta
[Musica]
miccoli
a prost
già
a scuola c'è
[Musica]
ascona c'è
pescara
all
c'è
no
[Musica]
ma io
sotto
no
[Musica]
poi
ansa
io no
basta
[Musica]
pescara c'è
no
[Musica]
ma c'è
pescara
no
9 mar
[Musica]
si no
[Applauso]